В ефірі «heute journal».
Доброго вечора.
Президент Франції Макрон
принаймні «географічно» наближується до України.
Сьогодні й завтра він відвідає
дві сусідні країни - Румунію і Молдову.
Звідти - недалеко до Києва.
Це підсилює очікування,
що Макрон разом із канцлером Шольцом
незабаром прибуде в Україну.
Легких перемовин не буде.
Вчора в інтерв'ю для «heute journal»
президент Зеленський
розкритикував вагання
Німеччини і Франції.
А на Донбасі час грає на руку не Україні.
Детальніше - Ральф Панічек.
І раптом - потрібно бігти, просто бігти
та якимось чином вибиратися.
Обстріли все ближче й ближче.
У Привіллі, що 20 км на північ від Сєвєродонецька,
озброєна поліція України - їхня остання надія.
Тут залишилося небагато людей.
Дякуємо поліції за те,
що вони допомагають рятувати людей.
Інших варіантів сьогодні немає.
Автобуси для евакуації не можуть доїхати до міста,
оскільки йде обстріл.
Ризикуючи власним життям Нацполіція України
намагається евакуювати людей.
Згідно з їхніми заявами, вдалось евакуювати
32 людини з регіону,
який впродовж днів знаходиться під обстрілами.
Евакуація звідси майже неможлива.
Передусім через те, що зруйновано всі мости
між Сєвєродонецьком та Лисичанськом,
який все ще під контролем України.
Сьогодні Росія висунула українським військовим,
які знаходяться там,
ультиматум - здатися.
Хоча найзапекліші бої зараз сконцентровані на Сході,
рани та страждання від війни
можна відчути по всій країні.
Прощання з одним із багатьох загиблих на війні героєм,
Олексієм Чубашевим,
солдатом і журналістом, який загинув кілька днів тому.
Ми ніколи не здамося.
Ми будемо продовжувати боротися
і захищати нашу родину,
наших дітей, наше майбутнє.
Але ціна надто висока,
адже ціна - це і людські життя.
У нас великі втрати,
однак ми не маємо іншого вибору.
Президент Зеленський сьогодні назвав битву за Донбас
однією з найжорстокіших в історії Європи.
Інтерв'ю Крістіана Зіверса
з мером Києва Віталієм Кличком
можна подивитися в «heute journal up:date»
або на ZDFheute.
А зараз до Великобританії:
прем'єрміністр Борис Джонсон зазнає
внутрішньополітичного тиску.
Про нього ходять плітки і
є невдоволення також у власній партії.
Тому Джонсон намагається перейти у наступ
і задовольнити своїх прихильників сенсаційними діями.
До них, наприклад, належить його заява
про намір ігнорувати
деякі частини договорів з ЄС щодо Брекзиту,
що матиме значні наслідки не лише для Північної Ірландії.
Також він хоче депортувати до Руанди
біженців різного походження.
Кажуть, так звана «Програма депортації до Руанди»
вжахнула навіть принца Чарльза.
З репортажем із Лондону: Андреас Штамм.
Політ настільки ж суперечливий, як і дорогий.
130 біженців мали б сісти на літак до Руанди,
але на борт зійдуть, очевидно, не більше семи.
За 600 тис. євро.
Усім іншим таки вдалося уникнути депортації
завдяки терміновими заявам на отримання притулку.
А тим часом осіб, які шукають притулку,
прибуває все більше.
Минулого року їх було майже 30 тис.
Того, хто прибуватиме нелегальним шляхом,
депортують до Руанди.
Заяви про надання притулку
можна подати лише в Руанді,
що навіть за умови позитивного рішення означатиме:
фінальна точка - Східна Африка і
більше жодного законного способу
прибути до Великобританії.
Уряд Великобританії перераховує сотні мільйонів до Кіґалі
та робить ставку на стримування процесу.
Що ж роблять контрабандисти людьми?
Замах на життя, навіть вбивство.
Перепливають через Ла-Манш у човнах,
котрі непридатні для плавання.
Потрібно зупинити цю «підприємницьку» діяльність.
Лунає критика та гучні протести:
такими депортаціями Великобританія
порушує міжнародне право.
У відкритому листі 25 англійських єпископів
засуджують таку поведінку
як аморальну та ганебну для країни.
ООН підкреслює складну ситуацію
щодо забезпечення прав людини у Руанді.
Важко гарантувати справедливу процедуру
надання притулку.
Це все - неправильні кроки,
особливо через те, що Британія була першою країною,
яка підписала Женевську конвенцію про статус біженців,
і має усі засоби, щоб впоратися з цією проблемою.
Британії - як укріплена фортеця,
пояснює сирієць Ібрагім під час телефонного дзвінку.
Він чекає на виліт у центрі депортації.
Він хотів побачити дружину і дитину, які зараз у Лондоні,
але, за словами правозахисників, законного шляху
із кризового регіону і зони бойових дій
не буде майже ні для кого.
Депортація навряд чи стане стримуючим фактором.
Якщо вони відправлять мене в Руанду,
я приїду знову.
Поки я не буду поруч з сім'єю -
мене ніщо не зупинить.
Я навіть готовий віддати за це своє життя.
Ібрагіма викреслили зі списку осіб,
котрі мали летіти до Руанди.
Після важкої юридичної тяганини, яка закінчилася
трохи менше ніж за годину
до запланованого вильоту.
Зрештою, термінові заяви,
які розглядає Європейським суд з прав людини,
все ж таки можуть врятувати від депортації.
Багато хто з самого початку застерігав,
що Дональд Трамп становитиме небезпеку
для американської демократії.
Однак те, що його перебування на посаді
закінчиться такою ескалацією,
приголомшило навіть найзапекліших опонентів.
Кривавий штурм Капітолію -
спроба державного перевороту,
оскільки Трамп не міг прийняти,
що основою будь-якої демократії є те,
що люди можуть усунути вас з посади.
Те, що Трамп підбурював своїх прихильників казкою
про фальсифікацію на виборах,
тоді збентежило навіть декого з близького оточення.
Про це повідомив і слідчий комітет у Вашингтоні.
Репортаж Бенджаміна Даніеля.
Заява Дональда Трампа щодо розслідування
штурму Капітолію
охоплює 12 сторінок.
12 сторінок, в яких немає нічого суттєвого.
Жодного суттєвого спростування,
жодного спростування доказів.
Тільки добре відомі небилиці, передусім -
про сфальсифіковані вибори.
Навіть після другого відкритого засідання слідчого комітету
важко зрозуміти, чому республіканці продовжують допускати,
щоб їхньому лідеру все сходило з рук.
Стає дедалі зрозумілішим, що навіть найближче оточення
Трампа від самого початку
дистанціювалося від його фантазій
про перемогу на виборах.
Я був деморалізований і подумав:
«О боже, якщо він справді вірить у це,
то він, мабуть, втратив зв’язок з реальністю».
Я був переконаний і тоді, і зараз,
що вибори не сфальсифікували.
Під час слухання також з’ясувалося, що Трамп
обдурив своїх прихильників на суму 250 млн доларів -
пожертвування, які він нібито хотів використати
для вирішення судових спорів.
Кампанія Трампа використала неправдиві звинувачення
у фальсифікації виборів,
щоб зібрати пожертвування
на сотні мільйонів доларів.
Вони стверджували, що використовують ці гроші
для судових спорів,
але вони цього не робили.
Таким чином, велика брехня була також
великою шахрайською схемою.
Розгляд подій 6 січня 2021 року триває.
Зрештою, його результати можуть стати підставою
для кримінального провадження проти Трампа.
У будь-якому разі зрозуміло,
що межа між істиною і брехнею стає дедалі чіткішою.
А тепер Гайнц Вольф з новинами.
Війна в Україні перешкоджає постачанню зерна
в деякі частини світу.
Асоціація фермерів Німеччини
хоче виробляти більше продукції в Німеччині.
На Дні фермера у Любеку президент Асоціації
Йоагім Руквід виступив
за тимчасове використання додаткових земельних площ.
За даними уряду Німеччини, компанія «Gazprom Germania»,
є ключовою щодо постачання газу в Німеччині
і від банкрутства її може врятувати
багатомільярдна позика.
На початку квітня уряд Німеччини взяв під контроль
німецьку дочірню компанію
російського державного концерну.
Російська енергетична компанія «Газпром» на 40%
скорочує максимальні обсяги поставок газу до Німеччини
через газопровід «Північний потік-1» в Балтійському морі.
Причиною, за словами компанії «Газпром»,
є затримка ремонтних робіт.
Міністерство економіки Німеччини заявило,
що наразі постачання газу забезпечене.
У віці 68 років помер від раку
барабанщик «Puhdys» Клаус Шарфшвердт.
З 1979 року він був учасником гурту «Puhdys» -
одного з найуспішніших гуртів НДР.
І до прогнозу погоди. Завтра на півночі хмарно,
температура від 18° до 25°.
В інших регіонах переважно сонячно.
Максимальна температура становитиме від 25° до 33°.
У четвер переважно без опадів,
температура від 20° до 32°.
На південному сході очікуються зливи та грози.
У п’ятницю та суботу буде сонячно та сухо.
Температура сягатиме до 37°.
Ось і все на сьогодні.
А зараз - другий тайм матчу Німеччина-Італія у Лізі націй.
О 00:45 випуск «heute journal up:date»
з Назан Гекдемір.
До побачення.